[Music]
well it's fall of course yeah fall means
a lot of things that's the time when
movie studios start rolling out their
more serious films especially biopics
those are movie biographies of real
people last year they released jay edgar
about jagger hoover the iron lady about
margaret thatcher and my week with
maryland about marilyn monroe right a
lot of new film biographies coming out
in the next few weeks i thought right
now we take a look at some of the movie
posters for these new celebrity biopics
do you want to see him this can be fun
[Music]
we're just going to do it
our first biopic is about the life of
honey boo boo's mom
yeah it's called lost in trans fats
[Applause]
this is a classy bit joe biden look at
look what he's got he's got look who's
still talking
bruce jenner has a bio pick out bruce
jenners is called 28 faces later
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he looks like a raccoon
you hear trash cans getting rattled
around at night and you shine a light
it's bruce jenner oh
that's that's one of them olympic devil
possums
hey mitt romney has a file pick out it
does oh shut up
yeah it's called tied to the roof dog
millionaire
hello
paul ryan vice presidential candidate
has one now paul ryan yeah it's called
marathon man well technically it was a
5k fun run
it was a news story
snoop dogg has a biopic out it's called
partial recall
chris christie has a biopic out it's
called eat pray eat
mel gibson has a biopic out really
thanks milo yeah
it's called mel gibson's how the jews
stole christmas
and finally you know larry king has a
biopic out well of course i would assume
that you would say that now that we've
been showing a bunch of biopics that if
you say larry king has one
i'm going to believe you that he has one
larry king's got a biopic out it's
called ice h5 a personal memoir
[Applause]
[Music]